So this October surprise published in The
New York Post last week about Joe Biden's
son, Hunter Biden is, I'm calling it, on the
verge of, although some people say it already
has spectacularly backfired on the Trump campaign.
The entire story published last week was supposed
to make Joe Biden look really, really bad.
It was supposed to prove that Joe Biden is
corrupt and a bad person and that so is his
son, Hunter Biden, corrupt, terrible, bad
person and a drug addict.
Not only has the story failed to hurt Joe
Biden so far, some of what is coming out as
being Joe Biden's alleged text messages to
his son are actually just making him look
like a good, kind, loving dad, an empathetic
person.
And Republicans have no idea what to do.
Now, before we even get into the specifics,
I want to let you know that we've since found
out that the writer of this story, the primary
writer of the New York Post story, Bruce Golding,
didn't even want his byline on the article
because he knew it lacked credibility.
Many New York Post staffers we've since found
out, thanks to a great piece in The New York
Times, New York Post staffers were saying
we shouldn't even be publishing this story.
We don't even trust the reliability of the
sources.
We questioned the timing.
And we now know Rudy Giuliani was a big factor
in pushing for the story's publication.
So no one, even internally, many at The New
York Post knew the story wouldn't shouldn't
be published.
But it was published.
OK, first of all, the underlying premise of
all of this is that Joe Biden did things as
vice president because Hunter Biden was on
the board of a Ukrainian energy company, including
getting a prosecutor fired.
That main story about Joe Biden getting a
prosecutor fired as as a gift to Hunter Biden
has long been debunked.
Even if you accept everything else in the
New York Post story is true, it does nothing
to change that.
The Biden prosecutor firing story is a lie.
Joe Biden was involved in the Ukrainian situation
with the prosecutor at Barack Obama's direction.
A coalition of countries was involved in that.
The idea that Biden went and did it for Hunter
Biden because of his consulting contract,
widely debunked already.
Then some texts are published as part of this
story.
Texts purported to be between Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden.
What we learned from those texts are or is
that Joe Biden is a caring dad and talks to
his son in a way that I've never even heard
of Donald Trump speaking to his children.
He seems to love and and support his son,
Hunter Biden.
It's clear Joe Biden loves his kids.
Generally speaking, it's not super clear that
Trump does, at least not in the way that resembles
healthy parenting.
That helps Joe Biden.
It makes Joe Biden look better.
And in the text, you also see, again, if the
text Sariel, Joe Biden say, give me a call,
because I am sure that my text messages are
a target.
And indeed, Joe Biden was right about that.
Now, thirdly, NBC News is reporting that federal
investigators are looking at whether the emails
allegedly describing activities by Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden supposedly found on a laptop
supposedly at a Delaware repair shop.
Those emails are potentially linked to a foreign
intelligence operation.
It's like it's happening again.
Barry PSMA apparently was hacked by the same
Russian intelligence unit that was involved
in the hacking of the Democratic National
Committee in 2016.
It's happening again.
That is now being investigated.
The Washington Post also reported overnight
that U.S. intelligence agencies warned the
White House last year that Trump's lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, was the target of an influence
operation by Russian intelligence.
Rudy Giuliani has since admitted that it's
possible.
I believe he said it's a 50/50 shot.
It's possible that he was working with a Russian
spy on this story.
Don't need to make any conspiracy.
Just look at what Rudy himself himself said.
So far, it does not seem that this October
surprise has hurt Joe Biden at all.
It may end up damaging Republicans.
It may end up damaging Donald Trump's campaign
more than anything else for a second.
Consider how absurd this all is.
The Trump campaign is trying to smear.
Joe Biden, by releasing the loving emails
and texts that he sent to his son.
Guys, rumor has it Joe Biden cried when his
first wife and kid died.
What a loser.
That's the level of stuff that they are resorting
to and trying to pull off here.
And really, I know that when Trump does his
rallies and talks about Hunter, the crowd
boos and cheers and jeers and whatever.
It doesn't seem to be.
People don't seem to be falling for it.
And what underlies this all to some degree.
Think about it is that Republicans consider
empathy and kindness and sensitivity to be
weaknesses.
Trump certainly sees it that way for sure.
This is why it doesn't make sense to argue
with them.
They can't behave like normal humans.
It could be a result of anger, fear, authoritarianism,
depending on which group you are talking about.
But you can't reason with them.
And as I read through the alleged texts between
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden, I like Biden more.
The only really groundbreaking thing here
that came from this, suppose it October surprise,
is that Rudy Giuliani is now being investigated
for potentially working with Russian spies.
Maybe doesn't come as a huge shock to us.
But so far, I know that there are some saying
there's much more coming and it's going to
be much worse.
Well, we've got 15 days to go.
OK, so they'd better get it out soon.
What is out so far does not strike me as even
remotely damaging to Joe Biden.
Within a few days, we will have post New York
Post story polling and we'll be able to see
for ourselves.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram at
David Pakman show.
And if you want to see me voting this weekend
powerfully voting, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.